curious how uh
ferruccia will do as it's its first time
in the candidates and he's been lying
low like uh
um last almost half a year like nobody's
seen him nobody's he's disappeared off
the planet off the grid after the world
wrapping and blitz he's completely
disappeared yeah he's just gone i mean i
saw him posting some pictures from
the caribbean on his social medias but
he's not playing in any event
maybe he's playing somewhere soon but
otherwise he's been completely inactive
and that's very unusual at such a young
age um i think he's is he still 18 yeah
yeah i think he turns 19 in the summer
right so
very curious how he will do
i would be very i hope you will win
actually because that doesn't
at least that's the way it looks it's
that's the only way we'll get a match
between uh
of uh magnus playing at least and uh
because i was about to ask you uh
recently there was another article where
magnus was saying i will i will
most likely not play another match and
do you think that is the only uh chance
if
ferugia wins the candidates that's the
only chance we have for magnus yeah he
was hinting at
before the match against nape already
within the team that it might be his
last match um
clearly he feels um classical chess is
or the pressure concerning with the
classical world championship match is
not worth it to play play another time
there goes so much preparation and the
effort
into playing there um
i really hope he will play regardless
but generally
carlson he does say
what he feels he um he's very upfront
about that
but you know people can change their
minds maybe once the challenger is known
and it's not for russia you'll be like
okay i'm gonna play anyway so it's
impossible to uh to say for me i just
hope that he will change his mind
regardless because um
would be i mean do be pity if the title
just
slips away or lets it go like that